[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Marietta
Slomka live aus Washington
als die Stadt heute morgen bei
strahlendem Sonnenschein erwachte hat
sich so manch einer die Augen gerieben
weil das was doch viele erwartet und die
Republikaner erhofft hatten nicht
eingetreten ist die Demokraten wurden
nicht brutal abgestraft obwohl das ja
bei mitturn elections durchaus üblich
ist was die Präsidentenpartei einen
Denkzettel erhält es kann zwar nach wie
vor sein dass im Kongress hier hinter
mir die Mehrheitsverhältnisse zugunsten
der Republikaner wechseln werden aber
triumphahl wird das nicht mehr
tatsächlich heißt der größte Verlierer
dieser Wahl nicht Joe Biden sondern
Donald Trump sein Kalkül ist nicht
wirklich aufgegangen Dominik leßmeister
berichtet
in diesen Stunden schaut Amerika gebannt
auf ein knappes Rennen vielerorts wird
noch ausgezählt eine Zitterpartie alle
Abgeordneten im Repräsentantenhaus
stehen zur Wahl im Senat geht es um gut
ein Drittel der Sitze die Republikaner
liegen im Repräsentanten House vorn doch
entschieden ist doch nichts 45 Sitze
sind noch offen in der zweiten Kammer im
Senat sieht es noch knapper aus die
Demokraten kommen auf 48 die
Republikaner auf 49 sitze
weiter umkämpft die Senatoren Sitze in
Georgia Nevada und Arizona in Georgia
wird es zu einer Stichwahl im Dezember
kommen der Anführer der Republikaner im
Repräsentantenhaus gibt sich in der
Nacht schon siegesgewiss
es ist klar dass wir das Haus
zurückerobern
doch dir hoffte rote Welle im Kongress
ist ausgeblieben führende Republikaner
räumen ein dass die Partei nicht in der
hofften Sieg einfahren dürfte
definitiv keine republikanische Welle es
war nicht wie ich gehofft hatte
einen wichtigen siegerringen die
Demokraten in Pennsylvania der Bock
receive John fetter Mann holt ein
senatsmandat das bisher die Republikaner
innerten der von Ex-Präsident Trump
unterstützte Kandidat viel durch
ich bin stolz dass wir mit den richtigen
Themen angetreten sind wir werden das
Recht auf Abtreibung schützen den
Mindestlohn erhöhen und wir werden für
unsere Demokratie einstehen
im Rennen um das gouverneurs-amt im
US-Bundesstaat Arizona deutet sich
dagegen eine Hängepartie an die
Demokratin Katie hops und die
Republikanerin carry Lake sind nur etwa
12.000 Stimmen auseinander
vor allem ein Wahlergebnis bei den
Republikanern dürfte ein schlechtes
Zeichen für Trumps sein der klare Erfolg
seines größten innerparteilichen Rivalen
Ron des Säntis ähnlich radikal wie Trump
bleibt er mit klarer Mehrheit Gouverneur
von Florida
danke für eure Unterstützung hier in
Florida wir haben nicht einfach nur die
Wahl gewonnen wir haben die politische
Landkarte neu geschrieben
noch hat sich keiner der beiden
offiziell für die republikanische
Präsidentschaftskandidatur beworben doch
Trumps Drogen gegen Disentis zeigen dass
er ihn für seinen größten Rivalen hält
Trump äußert sich inzwischen über seine
eigene Social Media Plattform
während die gestrige Wahl in gewisser
Weise etwas enttäuschend war war sie aus
meiner persönlichen Sicht ein sehr
großer Sieg für Joe Biden könnte es
glimpflicher ausgehen als vorhergesagt
dieses Foto twittert an sichtlich
entspannter Präsidentin der Weihnacht
die entscheidende Frage wer künftig im
Kongress das Sagen hat am Tag nach den
Zwischenwahlen ist das noch nicht
beantwortet
ist es jedenfalls ein Name den man sich
auch in Deutschland wird merken müssen
darüber will ich reden mit dem
Publizisten David from er gehört zum
konservativ republikanischen Lager und
war Redenschreiber für den früheren
Präsidenten George W Bush auf ihn ging
nach dem 11 September auch die weltweit
berühmt gewordene Formulierung Achse des
Bösen zurück David great to have you
here vielen Dank dass Sie Zeit für uns
haben
Dave sie sind ja ein klassischer
konservativer ein to believer wie man
bei den Republikanern sagt aber ein
entschiedener Gegner von Donald Trump
und sie haben gesagt bei diesen mitturms
haben die Wähler wirklich ja auch das
Schicksal der Nation in den Händen wie
geht es ihnen dann heute wie wir werden
Sie dieses Ergebnis
eine ungeheure Erleichterung auch wenn
wir das genaue Ergebnis noch nicht
kennen
ein
knapper Sieg der Republikaner oder ein
Irrer Erfolg der Demokraten der größte
den sie seit Washington
2002 also das ist schon eine Abstrafung
von Trump seine
Kandidaten von seinem schlagboten glatt
besiegt und geschlagen und die radikalen
die Gewalt androhen die haben auch
verloren
man hat einer seiner engsten und einer
seiner härtesten innerparteilichen
gegneron des Säntis ja einen großen
Erfolg errungen das haben wir gerade
schon in dem Stück gesehen wird er Trump
den naja ich sag mal den Partei Ton
streite ich machen wie schätzen Sie das
ein
big decision round the sad is over
hat seine Unterstützung bekommen
verdankt Trump sehr viel und er war sehr
loyal
er kanalisiert die Methoden und den
Diskurs von Trump etwas anders aber
psychologisch weiß man auch nicht so
genau bei ihm gemacht
er ist nicht vom Schlager eines Donald
Trump
hat allerdings
ein gutes Führungszeugnis
ob er den Mut hat der Trank so
herauszufordern ein Mann der so
skrupellos ist die Trump das wird man
sehen müssen
weil sie sagten gerade er ist
psychologisch normal manche sagen auch
es Trump mit Hirn des Handels aber er
ist ja trotzdem auch einer der sich zum
Beispiel überhaupt nicht aus abgesetzt
hat von den Wahlergebnis Leugnern also
der auch sich überhaupt nicht dazu
geäußert hat er ist auch einer der
diesen Kultur macht also es ist
eigentlich nicht der Art von
Republikaner den Sie gerne sehen würden
nämlich wieder wie eine Busch Zeit wie
eine Reagan Zeit das klassisch
konservative wohin treibt diese
republikanische Partei
der Preis
denken müssen in eine Zeit des
Nachdenkens gehen
sie haben Trump im powered sozusagen
aber er hat sie instrumentalisiert und
in der ganzen Stadt hört man nicht von
Menschen die ihr Kalkül hatten und sahen
das ist nicht aufgegangen
sie haben gedacht nur so Weg in diesem
Wald ein glatten Gewinn aber das hat
sich nicht eingestellt
[Musik]
auch konservativen stapeln
haben sie
das Abtreibungsrecht auf Abtreibung
angegriffen
michigana versucht umzukehren was hier
passiert unter dem Dach da drüben das
ist eine Niederlage und das spüren die
Republikaner
das könnte aber eventuell die Spaltung
auch noch weiter vorantreiben in dieser
Gesellschaft wie schätzen Sie das ein
ich denke may make it I thinking ich
kann es sogar besser werden das ist eine
der Lehren
der Kandidat für den Senat aus afri Sona
hat gepostet mit einem Bild von sich in
einem Wagen mit einem riesen
Maschinenpistole aber das ist er
natürlich nicht aber er dachte so sollte
er sich präsentieren und der hat die
Lektion die hat eine leere bekommen die
Drohung mit Gewalt Instabilität Angriff
auf Institutionen das funktioniert nicht
und auch diese hässlichen Witze nach dem
fürchterlichen Angriff gegen den Ehemann
von Nancy pelogy der operiert werden
müssen darüber Witze zu machen ich
glaube die haben hier eine leere
bekommen so redet man nicht in einer
kultivierten Gesellschaft in einer
Demokratie das geht nicht und das haben
die Amerikaner ihnen beigebracht
also eine doch eher optimistische
Einschätzung David from the have you
here much vielen lieben Dank das sieht
bei uns waren greater
ja den Amerikanern stehen politisch also
weiter auf jeden Fall sehr bewegte
Zeiten wovor mit womöglich noch ja
vielleicht auch dramatischen
Machtkämpfen innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei wir wollen jetzt
aber auch auf die außenpolitische
Bedeutung dieser Wahl blicken was
bedeuten diese mit terms für uns für
Europa für den Konflikt mit Russland und
den Krieg in der Ukraine dazu eine
Analyse von Claudia Bates
viele außenpolitische Ziele sind weniger
umstritten als innenpolitische aber
dennoch wird es nicht einfach
weitergehen wie bisher denn wenn die
Republikaner im Kongress die Mehrheit
haben können Sie alle Ausgaben stoppen
mein bäckerskonzern with meine größte
Sorge wäre die weitere Unterstützung für
die Ukraine die Vereinigten Staaten sind
mit Abstand der größte Waffenlieferant
mehr als zweimal so viel wie die gesamte
Europäische Union wenn die Unterstützung
hier nachlässt würde sich das sehr
ernsthaft auf die Möglichkeit der
Ukraine auswirken Russland
zurückzudrängen
Thema Ukraine Präsident beiden und
Präsident selensky waren sich einig die
USA unterstützen die Ukraine massiv die
problematisch mit Waffen mit Sanktionen
gegen den Angreifer Russland und dessen
Akteure von den Republikanern gab es
vereinzelt Kritik an den hohen Ausgaben
aber im Prinzip war man auf einer Seite
bis jetzt
unter republikanischer Mehrheit wird
kein Penny mehr in die Ukraine gehen
unser eigenes Land kommt zuerst
je mehr Radikale re:publikaner im
Kongress sitzen desto schwieriger wird
es für beiden die Mittel für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine zu bekommen
was dann auch für Europa und die NATO
Konsequenzen hat
wir wahrscheinlich sehen werden ist die
Aufforderung an Europa viel mehr zu tun
dieser Konflikt findet in Europa statt
und die Europäer sollten mehr machen als
im Moment noch gibt es eine große Anzahl
re:publikaner die die NATO unterstützen
die eine enge Beziehung zu Europa
unterstützen aber sicher würde Europa
insgesamt sein Vertrauen in die USA in
Frage stellen
Thema China eine republikanische
Mehrheit im Kongress würde beiden zu
einem noch aggressiveren Kurs drängen
Demokraten und Republikaner sind sich
einig beim Konflikt im Südchinesischen
Meer bei China als Handelsmacht
beim autoritären System und bei
Menschenrechtsfragen
auch den Besuch der mächtigen
DemokratInnen Nancy pelosy in Taiwan
haben die Republikaner ausdrücklich
unterstützt eine Kampfansage an China
außerdem bei Halbleitern und Mikrochips
riesige Investitionen um die hier in den
USA herzustellen und lithiumabbau für
die Herstellung von Batterien
beim Verhältnis zu China gibt es
zwischen den Demokraten und den
Republikanern keinen großen Unterschied
auch nicht übrigens zwischen der Trump
und der beiden Regierung Hilfe für die
Ukraine und was überhaupt die Interessen
der USA dort sind das ist etwas wo es
mehr Differenzen gibt
für Präsident beiden gilt es jetzt das
umzusetzen wofür er einen Konsens
braucht denn je näher die nächsten
Präsidentschaftswahlen Rücken desto mehr
hätte ein republikanischer Kongress ein
Interesse beiden zu untergraben und
damit eine republikanische
Präsidentschaft vorzubereiten
noch jedenfalls sind die USA der mit
Abstand größte der entscheidende und
unverzichtbare Unterstützer der Ukraine
selbstverständlich schaut man auch in
Kiew auf diese mit terms und hofft so
viel wie möglich noch erreichen zu
können solange die beiden Regierung am
Ruder ist insofern müsste es für die
Ukraine eine Genugtuung sein was Moskau
heute verkündete den Rückzug aus Teilen
der Region Hassan das ist zweifellos
eine herbe Niederlage für die russische
Armee aber was steckt dahinter warum
hört man aus Kiew gar kein gar keinen
lauten Jubel dazu gleich noch ein
Gespräch aber erstmal fast Christian von
Rechenberg die Ereignisse zusammen
es ist nicht die Mine eines Siegers mit
der russlandsverteidigungsminister das
zur Kenntnis nimmt was sein
oberkommandant für den ukraine-krieg
vorschlägt dass man sich zurückziehen
müsse aus Person und aus Teilen der
Region um das Leben unserer Soldaten zu
retten und ihre Kampfkraft auf Twitter
sind solche Bilder zu sehen Russland
zerstöre wohl gerade alle Brücken
entlang des Flusses nierpro im Süden der
Ukraine über den diapro Rücken die
Truppen nun offenbar hasst dich ab zum
anderen zum rettenden Ufer und neuen
Verteidigungslinien ja es ist eigentlich
die Aufgabe einer haltlosen Position
Russland stand vor der Entscheidung ob
sie die Truppen dort stehen lassen das
hätte bedeutet dass sie ohne Logistik
ohne Versorgung dastehen und dann
natürlich mit der Zeit einfach
neutralisiert werden oder ziehen Sie sie
zurück Bilder aus Version lassen
vermuten das Putins Armee bereits weg
ist offenbar verlassen weiter Zivilisten
die Stadt über den Fluss ob freiwillig
schwer zu sagen in Sicherheit ist Person
nicht nicht so lange Russland droht den
karovka-staudamm
zu sprengen es würde die ukrainische
Armee stoppen und wäre für die
Bevölkerung eine Katastrophe
Konstanze stelzenmüller ist bei uns
Expertin für Sicherheitspolitik und
transatlantische Beziehungen hier vom
Brookings Institution in Washington
guten Abend Frau stelzenmüller
wir beide hier das eigenartige ist ja
das Kiew überhaupt sich nicht in
irgendeiner Form positiv über diesen
Rückzug aus Rassen oder Teilen der
Region äußert wie schätzen Sie das ein
also der präsidentenberater von
Zielinski hat schon gesagt das könnte
eine Falle sein ich würde nicht sagen
das sind Falle aber Militärexperten
haben schon länger damit gerechnet weil
das jetzt zu Beginn des Winters
eigentlich die einzige durchhaltbare
Position für die russischen Truppen ist
um sich zu regenerieren wieder
aufzustocken und eine Frühlingsoffensive
vorzubereiten eine Position auf der
anderen Seite des mikrops Flusses wäre
für sie so exponiert und gefährlich
gewesen dass dieser Rückzug zwingend war
naja es kommt jetzt so gleichzeitig auch
mit diesem Hinweis man sei in Russland
bereit für Verhandlungen das wird auch
sehr sehr sehr zurückhaltenden Kiew
aufgenommen ich glaube völlig zu Recht
also
es ist glaube ich ganz klar dass
Russland das Putin und der Kreml und mit
ihm die gesamte russische Führung
ich glaube
verhandelndes Verhandlungsbereitschaft
nur äußern um Zeit zu gewinnen die
werden erst zu Behandlung wirklich
bereit sein wenn ihnen klar ist dass sie
militärisch nicht mehr gewinnen können
aber jetzt noch mal hier auf die
amerikanische Außenpolitik die ja so
wichtig für die Ukraine ist blicken
glauben Sie dass die Unterstützung so
bleiben wird oder vielleicht sogar jetzt
noch mal zunimmt wo die mitturms vorbei
sind und beiden keine Rücksichten mehr
nehmen muss also zunächst muss man sagen
durch diesen doch beachtlichen Erfolg
für beiden und die zentristischen
Positionen der Demokraten und auch auf
der republikanischen Seite haben die
Europäer Zeit gewonnen aber ich glaube
in europäischen Hauptstädten ist man
dringend beraten diese gewonnene Zeit
auch zu nutzen weil es sehr von den
Dynamiken jetzt im Kongress abhängt und
der von der Führung der Republikaner wie
groß der Druck auf beiden wird wie groß
die Kontrolle werden wird übrigens die
Kontrolle ist eigentlich hier das
Codewort für wir wollen wir wollen bei
allem mitreden und euch bei allen
blocken dann gibt es auch eben diese
diese hartrechte make America great
again die magerfraktion die auch schon
klar gesagt hat wir wollen überhaupt
keine Mittel für die kleine mehr wenn
die aus irgendwelchen Gründen doch
Einfluss gewinnen sollten oder gar die
Oberhand dann wird es für die Europäerin
für die Ukraine sehr schwierig werden
der wird from sagte gerade im rausgehen
noch ist schon der Beitrag lief das war
heute ein ganz schlechter Tag für Putin
sehen Sie das auch so also ganz so
optimistisch bin ich noch nicht weil wir
noch nicht alles wissen und erst in
Anfang Dezember vermutlich genau wissen
werden wie der Senat und der
konstituiert ist aber trotzdem das war
auf jeden Fall kein guter Tag für Putin
aber wir wissen auch das Putin immer
sehr gut darin gewesen ist auch sehr
schlechten lagen irgendwelche Vorteile
rauszuziehen das ist es gibt überhaupt
keinen Grund für uns und entspannen das
sicherlich nicht Frau Stelzmüller danke
ihnen fürs hier sein
ja der Krieg in der Ukraine die Wahlen
in den USA das sind heute natürlich die
beherrschenden weltpolitischen Themen
aber natürlich gibt es auch aus
Deutschland heute jede Menge Nachrichten
die wichtigsten hat jetzt Heinz Wolf in
Mainz und zunächst zur wirtschaftlichen
Situation hier zu Lande und wie sie vom
Sachverständigenrat auch die
Wirtschaftsweisen genannt eingeschätzt
wird sie haben heute ihr neues Gutachten
vorgelegt und die mehr als 400 Seiten an
Bundeskanzler Scholz übergeben die
experten erwarten für dieses Jahr noch
ein Wachstum von 1,7 Prozent im nächsten
allerdings ein Minus von
0,2%. bei der Inflationsrate rechnen sie
nach 8% in diesem Jahr für 2023 mit 7,4
Prozent
die Sachverständigen empfehlen unter
anderem einen höheren Spitzensteuersatz
oder einen energiesoli für besser
verdienende außerdem raten die Experten
die Atomkraftwerke über den April
nächsten Jahres hinauslaufen zu lassen
der heutige 9 November ist Gedenktag für
gleich mehrere historisch bedeutender
Ereignisse
1938 begannen die Nationalsozialisten
mit der offenen Gewalt gegen jüdische
Menschen in der Reichspogromnacht
setzten sie Synagogen und andere
jüdische Einrichtungen in Brand
Geschäfte wurden zerstört viele jüdische
Menschen getötet oder verschleppt an
diese Gräueltaten wurde heute vielerorts
erinnert wie hier in Chemnitz
der 9 November steht aber auch für den
Fall der Mauer 1989 bundesweit gab es
dazu mehrere Gedenkveranstaltungen bei
der zentralen in Berlin erinnerten die
Teilnehmer an die jahrzehntelange
innerdeutsche Teilung und gedacht auch
der Opfer an der deutsch-deutschen
Grenze
na diesen Tag der Erinnerung an den
Mauerfall ist der ehemalige DDR
Bürgerrechtler Werner Schulz gestorben
bei einer Veranstaltung im Schloss
Bellevue zum 9 November in einem
Beileidsschreiben an die Witwe würdigte
Bundespräsident Steinmeier Werner Schulz
als einen Menschen der sich aus vollem
Herzen und mit großer Kraft sein Leben
lang für Demokratie und die Freiheit
einsetzte ein Nachruf von Christian
Läpple
der 72-Jährige Werner Scholz ein
Ostdeutscher der sich stets einmischte
ein unbeugsamer Streiter für Demokratie
unabhängig und gerne auch unbequem für
ihn war der 9 November ein Glücksfall
meine Generation hat aus eigener Kraft
diese Demokratie errungen das ist eine
unglaublich hoher Wert den wir
eingebracht haben wir hätten ja noch
eine Menge zu tun gehabt in der DDR es
war ja nicht so dass alles aufgeräumt
wurde gegen den Strom zu schwimmen das
war das Motto von Werner Schulz der
gebürtige Sachse studierte
Lebensmittelchemie schloss sich aber
bald Oppositionsgruppen an er war
Mitbegründer des neuen Forum und
Mitglied der Grünen bis zuletzt trotz
aller Ärgernisse neben allem Schrecken
der mich erfasst hat als ich von dem Tod
hörte ist mir bewusst geworden ohne
Menschen wie ihn hätten wir den 9
November 1989 überhaupt nicht erlebt
echte Demokratie ist möglich das war die
Welt von Werner Schulz gestorben am 9
November 2022
die Bundesregierung hat sich ein
weiteres Mal mit geplanten Geschäften
chinesischer Investoren bei deutschen
Unternehmen beschäftigt
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck gab
nach einer Kabinettssitzung bekannt dass
in zwei Fällen der Einstieg eines
Investors untersagt worden ist fragen
wir nach bei unserem Wirtschaftsexperten
Frank Bethmann wie wird das begründet in
beiden Fällen handelt es sich um
Unternehmen aus der Halbleiterbranche
und da sagt die Bundesregierung
inzwischen da müssen wir genauer
hinschauen da geht es um
Sicherheitsfragen und das ist eine
Schlüsseltechnologie die es zu schützen
gilt der heute ausgesprochene
Verkaufsstopp betrifft zum einen eine
Produktionsstätte des Dortmunder
shipherstellers elmos der Halbleiter für
die Autoindustrie fertigt und zum
anderen ers electronic ein bayerisches
Unternehmen das Maschinen zur
ship-prüfung baut wichtig ist die
politische Botschaft dass wir eine
offene Marktwirtschaft sind das
Investitionen auch aus dem Ausland hier
gewollt und willkommen sind
aber eine offene Marktwirtschaft ist
keine naive Marktwirtschaft aus Sicht
des Bundeswirtschaftsministers verfolgt
China eine strategische Ausrichtung beim
Aufkauf ausländischer Firmen die man
unterbinden will doch drohte hier
wirklich ein Ausverkauf von
Schlüsseltechnologie im Fall von elmos
gibt es Zweifel die
Produktionstechnologie in Dortmund gilt
als veraltet Frank Bethmann vielen Dank
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball-Bundesliga
von heute Abend der erste fC Köln hat
gegen Bayer Leverkusen eins zu zwei
verloren
die deutschen Handball Frauen haben bei
der Europameisterschaft in Montenegro
ihr letztes Vorrundenspiel gegen Spanien
verloren gerade gegen die Partie zu Ende
21 zu 23 trotzdem haben die Deutschen
den Einzug in die Hauptrunde geschafft
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 2 16 29 32 47 49 und die
Superzahl 5 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
Sie auflotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
Seite 557
so viel von hier aus Mainz jetzt geht es
nochmal weiter in Washington mit Marias
das war jedenfalls ein denkwürdiger Tag
den wir von hier beobachtet haben und
wir wollen jetzt zum Schluss noch mal
eine Bilanz ziehen mit unserem USA
Korrespondenten MRT wissen immer wenn
wir noch mal ans Kapitol denken und ein
Blick darauf werfen und dann die
Ereignisse vom 6 Januar 2021 erinnern
den Sturm aus Kapitol den Sturm auf die
Demokratie kann man dann heute
optimistisch zumindest sagen die
Mehrheit der Amerikaner hat uns mit
dieser Wahl gesagt so wollen wir nicht
sein und so sind wir nicht ich glaube
ganz vorsichtig optimistisch aber das
war ja ein Umsturzversuch und seitdem
gab es sowas wie ein Umsturzversuch in
Zeitlupe da sind ja Kandidaten
angetreten die in den Bundesstaaten
wichtige Ämter besetzen wollten
gouverneursämter innen und
Justizminister um auch Einfluss auf
künftige Wahlen zu gewinnen die sind
jetzt nicht gewählt worden mit anderen
Worten haben die Wähler ein Stück diesen
Umsturz versucht abgebremst aber die
Brandschutzmauer die sie jetzt errichtet
haben ist vielleicht nicht breit genug
nicht dick genug weil es sind über 200
Kandidaten in verschiedene Ämter in die
Parlamente Bundesstaaten teilweise auch
hier hinein gewählt worden die der Lüge
von der angeblich gestohlenen Wahl
anhängen so dass das natürlich immer
noch eine Gefahr wird und ich glaube
viel steht und fällt damit ob Donald
Trump antritt und das dann wieder weiter
befeuert wir wissen ja noch nicht wie am
Ende die Mehrheitsverhältnisse sein
werden also es könnte das Regieren
könnte für Joe Biden auf jeden Fall auch
wenn er heute sicherlich ein eher
erleichterter Präsident ist dann doch
künftig schwieriger werden ja das ist
sicher so es wird viel schwieriger wenn
man den Senat wenigstens halten könnte
kann er noch einiges bewegen
außenpolitisch Konstanze Stelzmüller
sagt es aber auch was die richterämter
angeht hier im Land aber natürlich ist
auch die Hoffnung dabei dass unter den
Republikanern einige sind die eine Lehre
aus dieser Wahl ziehen dass der
trumpismus nicht der richtige Weg ist
nicht der erfolgreiche Weg um künftig
Wahlen zu gewinnen so dass vielleicht
der ein oder andere Republikaner im
Repräsentantenhaus vielleicht auch im
Senat bei Einzelprojekten mit der Agenda
von Joe Biden stimmt Dankeschön Elmar
und auf jeden Fall bleibt das hier
spannend in den US und das ist gut
möglich dass der Kampf um die
Präsidentschaft in zwei Jahren dann auch
nicht zwischen dem dann fast 82-jährigen
beiden und dem dann 78-Jährigen Trump
ausgefochten wird sondern wer weiß es
könnte auch sein dass uns da eine ganz
andere ganz neue Konstellation erwartet
für heute verabschieden wir uns hier
jedenfalls jetzt erstmal aus Washington
DC die Kollegen vom heute journal Update
werden gegen halb eins sie mit frischen
Informationen und Gesprächen weiter auf
dem Laufenden halten und auch jetzt
gleich im auslandsjournal geht es
natürlich um die Wahlen hier in den USA
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend die kalt von tief philomena
zieht morgen weiter ostwärts erreicht
dann auch Polen Ungarn und Österreich
dann übernimmt das hochcharly mit mehr
Sonnenschein aber auch Nebel und
Hochnebel heute Nacht aber regnet es
noch vor allen Dingen im alten Vorland
aber auch zwischen dem Erzgebirge und
dem Schwarzwald einige gewittrige
Regenschauer gibt es in
Schleswig-Holstein sonst ist es meist
trocken und zum Teil auch klar wie hier
an der Mosel oder auch in der Eifel dort
wird es dann noch am kühlsten da sinken
die Werte in dieser Nacht auf 5 Grad
sonst gehen die Temperaturen auf 10 bis
6 Grad zurück und morgen ist es ähnlich
mild wie heute mit 11 Grad hier im
Vogtland am Alpenrand oder auch im
Sauerland und bis zu 16 Grad am
Niederrhein morgen Vormittag kann das
seinem Alpenrand noch etwas regnen das
lässt danach mittags auf jeden Fall nach
und am Vormittag ziehen noch dichtere
Wolken hier über Norddeutschland die
werden dann am Nachmittag auch etwas
lockerer werden der Wind kommt aus West
südwestlichen Richtung ist aber im
Wesentlichen nur an der Küste spürbar
und am sonnigsten wird es am und in den
nächsten Tagen geht das mit ruhigem
Novemberwetter weiter mal stört etwas
Nebel oder Hochnebel das dann aber vor
allen Dingen in den Flusstälern
Süddeutschlands an der Donau zum
Beispiel oder auch am Bodensee am
Sonntag in der Wind etwas zu und damit
verzahnt der Nebel auch kein Problem
mehr darstellen die Temperaturen liegen
dann bei 7 bis 17 Grad und mit diesen
heizenergiefreundlichen Aussichten
wünsche ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend